اصيب شاب فلسطيني برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال مواجهه اندلعت في مخيم
الفارعه جنوب طوباس في الضفه الغربيه صباح
اليوم وقال مراسل الجزيره ان اشتباكات
اندلعت في المكان بعد اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال المخيم ودفعها باكثر من عشر
اليات عسكريه الى داخله ومحيطه وتمركز
كذلك قناصه من الجيش الاسرائيلي على اسطح
المنازل وطلب الجنود بعض المدنيين بالخروج
من منازلهم وتسليم
انسهم معنا من طوباس مراسل الجزيره ليث
جعار ليث تقف وخلفك اليات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ما هي ابرز مشاهداتك لما يجري
والمعلومات المتوفره
لديك نعم بالفعل بدات عمليه عسكريه
اسرائيليه في مخيم الفارعه الى الجنوب من
محافظه طوباس في هذه الل لحظات وسط وصول
تعزيزات عسكريه اسرائيليه بين الفينه
والاخرى من حاجز الحمراء الى الجنوب من
المحافظه وصولا الى محيط مخيم الفارع
الاحتلال يغلق كافه مداخل مخيم الفارعه في
هذه اللحظات وسط اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه
تدور حتى هذه اللحظه نرصد هنا في هذه
الصوره تحرك للاليات العسكريه وهنا تتواصل
بهذ في هذه النقطه الاليات الع العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي لا تزال تتواجد في عند
المداخل الرئيسيه للمخيم حيث ما يزيد عن
25 اليه عسكريه برفقه جرافه وصلت بالفعل
الى مخيم الفارعه
وتبعا للتعزيزات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
التي يبدو اننا فقد في محيط مخيم الفارعه
حيث بدات الاشتباكات
والانفجارات تفضل ل نعم اذا يعني العمليه
العسكريه متواصله حصار هناك حصار نعم هناك
حصار للقوات الخاصه الاسرائيليه ل منزل في
مخيم الفارعه ووسط اشتباكات وانفجارات لا
تزال متتاليه حتى هذه اللحظه هنا على
الصوره الاخرى من المخيم وعلى منطقه مطله
للمخيم ايضا تواجد لاليات الاحتلال
العسكري التي قامت بانزال قبل قليل
القناصه الاسرائيليه وتوجهت بين
الاشجار في محاوله لاحكام السيطره بالكامل
على مخيم الفارعه مخيم الفارعه يشهد منذ
اشهر اشتباكات واقتحامات متواصله لجيش
الاحتلال وايضا قبل حوالي اسبوع من الان
كان هناك اقتحام ايضا للمخيم ادى ذلك
لارتقاء عدد من الشهداء وايضا عدد من
الاصابات في هذه اللحظه قوات الاحتلال لا
تزال تحاصر مخيم الفارعه هناك اشتباكات
مسلحه تدور في المنطقه ويعني الانفجارات
لا تكد تهدا في هذه اللحظات نسمع اصوات
اطلاق نار ما بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وجيش الاحتلال الذي يحاصر المخيم حيث تمكن
قبل قليل وحسب مصادر من داخل المخيم
بانسحاب منفذ او ال احد المطاردين الذين
حاصرهم الاحتلال داخل هذا المنزل بعد ايه
اصابه شاب في محيط المنزل اثناء
الاشتباكات
ليتمكن المطاردين من الانسحاب والخروج من
داخل هذا المنزل الذي حاصرته القوات
الخاصه الاسرائيليه ودفعت بالتعزيز
العسكريه الاسرائيليه الى محيط المخيم من
مخيم الفارعه في طوباس نشكرك حتى اللحظه
مراسل الجزيره ليث
شعر